tout pouvoir à bamako paris ce serait
donc résolu à accepter le mali après
neuf ans de lutte anti djihadistes la
france s'apprête à annoncer son retrait
du pays annonce qui pourrait intervenir
ce soir ou demain en marge d'un sommet
union européenne union africaine prévue
à bruxelles cyril payen bonjour bonjour
on décrypte ensemble évidemment cette
annonce imminente l'agenda du jour
commençons par en parler il est assez
dense oui et puis c'est une réunion
informelle qui se transforme en fête en
mini sommet pour acter par la parole le
présidentielle emmanuel macron et bien
ce cette séparation de cette relation
entre le mali et la france effectivement
donc il y a encore beaucoup
d'interrogations et le président
français nous a habitués à être capable
de beaucoup de coups de théâtre
notamment sur le le calendrier alors est
ce que comme il est prévu il va annoncer
il va faire cette grande déclaration en
ouverture de ce sommet demain à
bruxelles qui est un sommet qui devrait
acter le l'européanisation de cette
déclaration c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas uniquement la rupture des relations
bilatérales entre la france et le mali
mais bien une partie du monde les pays
de la région la communauté
internationale avec une un gouvernement
de transition une junte militaire qui
n'a pas respecté bien le chronogramme
électoral qu'on lui demandait de
respecter complètement de de redonner le
pouvoir démocratiquement donc ça peut
être demain on dit aussi pourquoi pas ce
soir à l'issue de ce mini sommet qui va
réunir finalement beaucoup de monde il
ya trois chefs d'état ouest africains
qui font le déplacement à l'elysée il le
représentant de l'alloeu de la cedeao de
l'union africaine évidemment mais
également les européens trois membres
éminents
de l'union européenne a promis lieu
charles michel qui fait le déplacement
et il ya une délégation aussi américaine
donc on voit bien qu'on essaie
d'internationaliser on voit bien aussi
qu'il va y avoir deux des négociations
notamment sur le devenir de cette force
takouba la force européenne
qui est donc des négociations en cours
pour essayer d'entériner une déclaration
commune parce que le message
présidentiel est très très clair c'est
bien
l'europe qui se hisse à qui s'adresse au
monde 1 pour dire qu'on quitte le mali
dans les prochains mois à partir de
demain concrètement que va annoncer
emmanuel macron dans les heures qui
arrivent alors donc dans les faits c'est
un programme qui est déjà annoncée c'est
à dire en fait il fallait depuis le 10
juin dernier mais ne la croit avait
annoncé qu'on allait un peu baisser les
effectifs de cette opération barkan
cette opération anti djihadistes qui a
presque dix ans dont on a fait le tour
du cadran de lettres de l'aveu même de
l'état major français il fallait trouver
une porte de sortie le problème c'est
que effectivement c'est un
redimensionnement qui passe de 5000
hommes en gros a à peu près 2000 et vers
une fin de ces opérations qui est un peu
accéléré c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et ça c'est sous la pression de de
bamako puisqu'il y est les opérations
militaires d'un côté puis aussi c'est
relation schizophrénique je dirais avec
les états leurs relations diplomatiques
qui sont au plus mal donc il va annoncer
évidemment lors le la fin de deux
barques annonçait sur le plan logistique
que ça va prendre de six à douze mois
donc il ya le message politique il y
aura ensuite la réalité du terrain mais
c'est un effectif en cela qu'il est
annoncé avec la môle à la fin pardon
pour terminer de fait de l'opération
takouba qu'elle a cette force spéciale
européenne qui va donc cesser d'exister
merci beaucoup cyril la merci pour les
cryptages on retrouve dans la suite de
paris directeur
[Musique]